and we are underway at wrigley field in
chicago and now it's kevin newman
and golfed out to left
caring and got a home run for kevin
newman
number one of the year and the bucks
have an early lead there's home run
number one well it's not getting knocked
down like it was in the last couple of
nights yeah that one looked like a
cutter that's
trying to run it in on him
allowed newman to drop the head down to
the to the baseball as it was moving in
at him full count see moran is seeing
the ball well
he got him
what a beautiful pitch he had been
working him away and he throws this
front door cutter david body who's five
out of 14 two home runs that's a 357
average and five rbis
and a swing and a miss went away from
the fastball and he strikes out bodhi on
three pitches left on left rizzo and bro
filling up the strike zone
looped out to right here there's the
second out here's javier baez now the
pitch
swing and a miss and wow is that
good work from brault fastball away and
one two three go the cubbies after one
and brought's in the zone he can be as
good as just about anybody in baseball
as steven souza junior steps in here's
the one-two pitch and he chases a high
fastball to souza and right now steven
bralt is dominating through two innings
rand called out on strikes his first
time here at first one away we're in the
third
on a bounce bayas will step on the bag
throw to first that's a 6-3 inning
ending
double play designated hitter is the
32-year-old from terre haute indiana
josh begley
swinging a miss in a high fastball
strikes out his support cool tucker is
stepping into the box fastball strike
three call tucker caught looking
for lester that's his second strikeout
of the day
jacob stallings will lead it off for the
pirates
strike three called and stallings is
retired one away here in the fit two
away and it'll bring up adam frazier
wow
four strikeouts all looking for lester
here's contreras
this is ripped into left field it'll
bounce off the wall contreras rounds
first he is digging for second the throw
the slide he is
safe a leadoff double here in the fifth
for wilson contreras the cubs first hit
of the game fires a strike
two second base now the ball could have
beat contreras it checks up a little bit
as it bounces in the outfield grass to
second base
but wilson with a great slide head first
slide in the second he goes in with both
hands and then pulls the right one away
and the left hand goes into the bag
and that's how he's safe if he goes in
with the right hand he's going to be out
here in the bottom half of the fifth
inning cubs in business a lead off
double by wilson contreras so he's at
second kyle schwarber at the plate cubs
down one pirates up one to nothing
schwarber deep center tucker's not gonna
get it
cops are gonna tie it i believe
contreras goes through the stop sign and
a throw to the plate and gets away from
stallings they had contreras nailed at
the plate but the ball got away it
looked like will venable was holding
contreras up but he decided to go
through anyway would not have been safe
had stalling's been able to hang on to
that throw as tucker played that ball
off the wall got it into the cutoff man
and contreras went through the stop sign
the ball got past stallings to tie the
game at one
in the dirt for ball
four and hap draws a walk it'll bring up
nico horner men at first and second and
just one away here in the bottom half of
the fifth inning tie game 1-1 cubs and
pirates a good bat for ian off the bench
and
and i think they're going to go back out
and look at cool i i think his finger is
the blister on his finger
his index finger is just making it tough
i'm guessing they're they're
they're getting blood on the baseball
and that's what stallings is probably
telling the trainer
that
it's just not
nothing you can do once that blister
pops it just keeps tearing apart
it's very difficult
and he is going to be done for the day
yep so just too much to overcome there
for chad cool there will be a pitching
change
here at wrigley field
the hustle here is it's really coming
down
so we will step aside here
and be back
as the cubs
when we resume will bat in the bottom of
the ninth still batting for eric
gonzalez
base hit to left
stallings is going to be set by joey
cora might be a play on him he's
out
on a collision
and bell will take over at second
so stallings wondering about the block
rule but
it looked like a pretty clean play to me
ball took him there wilson had no choice
what a beautiful throw by schwarber as
that play is developing i'm thinking oh
the problem the throws probably got to
come into second base here
but schwarberg
launches one homework yeah contreras is
fine there and
stalin certainly within his right to
make contact so the pirates opt not to
pinch run and you can understand that
too
stalwix is not fleet of foot
if if they were the home team they
probably do run for him because that's
the slam dunk winning run as the road
team obviously that is not the case
so david ross is out chatting with pat
holberg
derrick shelton the pirates manager is
also on the field to get some sort of
explanation so an old-fashioned
collision at home plate and now the
umpires are going to get together at
least pat holberg will talk to bill
welke the crew chief
how about that for some extra excitement
with this new rule
literally right off the
bat they're going to go to review
so the call is upheld
by is all for four a chance to win it
let me see stalin setting up off the
corner and that's
gonna do it javi baez with a base hit
bodhi scores cubs win
cubs win 2-1 the final in 11.
and the crowd goes wild and the cubs
will come out for a socially distanced
celebration in the middle of the diamond
good stuff fellas
[Applause]
it's a series sweep
[Music]
and the cubs are off to a sizzling seven
and two start